when we think of farmers what image
comes to mind
chances are it's a man
but did you know that many rice farmers
are women
aside from being mothers and wives they
are farmers too
at least 500 million women around the
world are engaged in rice cultivation
women account for 47 of the global
agricultural labor
however 87 of women's agricultural labor
is unpaid
and unrecognized the role of women in
farming families varies in different
parts of the world
in sub-saharan africa and in south asia
women
are perceived to play supporting roles
and do not participate in
decision-making
while women in southeast asian countries
enjoy less restrictive social and gender
norms
women farmers have insufficient access
to farming resources
technologies and opportunities which are
mainly geared toward men
farmers in the philippines
women comprise around 26 of agricultural
workers
the country is the eighth largest rice
producer in the world
in 2019 the philippines grew more than
13 million metric tons of rice
producing rice is not an easy task
farmers start
working before sunup and endure
long hours under the sun to provide us
with our staple source of energy
despite this farmers are still among the
poorest in the country
they posted the highest poverty
incidents among the basic sectors in the
recent years
being a farmer is hard enough but
being a woman in a farming family can be
harder
around 35 of filipino women farmers
render
unpaid work 6 out of 10 unpaid women
family workers in the country
operate in the agriculture sector one of
the fundamental problems is that women
are not commonly recognized as farmers
their farm work is seen as an extension
of their duties at home
women's unpaid farm labor adds to their
burden of being the family's primary
caregiver
and homemaker to add to this
women generally have limited access to
resources
learning opportunities and farming
technologies
this hinders women from reaching their
full potential and locks them in a cycle
of low productivity
and poverty women in farming families
need support to work on the farm in a
way that
recognizes their other roles in the
family
programs and policies should recognize
women's role in agriculture and create
conditions that would make their
engagement beneficial
these can be realized through learning
and training opportunities and
credit facilities or financial products
that can help run their farms or
run farms single-handedly in more
efficient and effective ways
an enabling environment for women
farmers will help them access tools and
training to increase their productivity
this is the first step towards realizing
women's potential to be change agents in
their communities
women managing farms and making
decisions means higher income for
farming families
more resources and better access to
basic services like
education and healthcare this will give
farming families a fighting chance
against
poverty provide their families more
opportunities to better their lives
and create a positive ripple effect
making happier
and healthier communities
[Music]
you